[Music]
all right amazon kicked off its prime
day sales event today but before you
start filling up your card it's
important to ask are those deals really
worth it nationally recognized savings
expert andrea warrock has been tracking
prime day for the past seven years she's
got the inside scoop on what to buy what
to skip how to save more
don't assume amazon prime day deals will
be the best you can find some retailers
like target walmart kohl's and best buy
will host their own sales events around
the same time offering big discounts on
a variety of brands similar to what
you'll see at amazon targets deal days
is going on through the 13th walmart is
hosting deals for days
for five full days through the july 14th
we're also seeing sales from best buy
kohl's ebay
and so many other stores track prices
because prices will fluctuate and check
price history camelcamelcamel.com
provides historical pricing data for
products sold on amazon to help you make
a better buying decision on prime day
this way you know if the item you're
eyeing is in fact the lowest price it's
been sold for all year long coupon cabin
sidekick tool will automatically apply
coupons or cashback when you shop edison
mail's price alert will let you know if
your prime day purchase goes on sale
afterwards
and you still have time to earn credit
toward prime day promotions if you apply
for an amazon credit card you're looking
getting an instant hundred dollars to
use towards prime day plus you're gonna
get five percent back on all those
purchases so if that's a credit card you
were considering getting get it now and
use that credit
also she says review return policies
just because something is sold on amazon
doesn't mean the item qualifies for the
site's lax return policy in fact many
third-party sellers have stricter return
options so pay attention to who you're
buying from and review their policy so
you don't get stuck with something you
simply don't like
our